you know I had always hoped right before  I died my life flashed before my eyes  and I would see wonderful things but as  I was hanging up there IIIi didn't  really see much of anything  I did see you  No  this is crazy that's why you were dead  a lie dad I don't think so you're  talking yeah you're special  he's special  like the multi-purpose to a god and  that's why I need you to help me get  home  you want to go home so you can have love  but you ran away cuz nobody loves you  Shh shut up you can just say everything  that comes into your head that's bad  talking Oh Manny I think your Wang is  guiding us home it's magic  people don't like other people's farts  is that why you don't fart in front of  me I just like to do it alone more hold  it in that's what you're supposed to do  that's so sad  I'm saying and we danced and it was  beautiful  don't be afraid yeah their swag so I  smoked thought would see some lodgings  rest on horses you need to see the  preacher  yes